he's already the world's oldest leader
but 89 year old robert mugabe isn't
about to retire quietly he's campaigned
hard in this election and despite his
promises to respect the outcome some
fear he'll do anything to win if you go
into a process and join in a competition
where there are only two outcomes win or
lose you can be both you either win or
you lose if you lose then you must
surrender to those who have won if you
win those who were lost must also
surrender to you and this is it will do
so you comply with the rules his main
opponent is his longtime rival Morgan
Chang Hirai
a man who's challenged Mugabe in the
past three elections only to be defeated
by vote rigging and violence he's been
the prime minister in a tense
power-sharing government waiting for the
chance to oust Mugabe for good but still
the elections expected to be closed and
with claims that the voter roll is
packed with the names of up to a million
dead voters the result could be
manipulated human rights groups a
warning of trouble ahead
we're very seriously concerned about the
potential for widespread violence if the
election result does not go President
Mugabe is way as we saw in 2008 when he
lost the first round of elections we saw
widespread killings beatings and torture
across the country many MDC or perceived
MDC supporters were punished by soldiers
and zanu-pf supporters for voting
against zanu-pf this was Zimbabwe five
years ago the time of the last
action we found the shops empty of food
because of hyperinflation and out in the
rural areas children going hungry
because of the shortages the economy is
recovering now in large part because of
the power sharing government but Mugabe
has claimed much of the credit and can
still count on significant support so
much is at stake in this election and
not just for Zimbabwe millions of
Zimbabweans have fled here to South
Africa over the past decade because of
the economic and political turmoil so
many are just waiting for stability so
they can return home this church in
Johannesburg is a shelter for hundreds
of Zimbabwean refugees and they too are
divided over whether Mugabe should stay
or go Morgan son cried they get a chance
an opportunity to to be a president
maybe you stabilize our economy or the
opposition parts from Zimbabwe they're
being controlled by the Western powers
so you think Mugabe should win yeah what
we are expecting is a big change because
all of us here we are you in desperate
because we are we were suffering because
President Mugabe may yet bow to defeat
or extend his 33 years in power with a
legitimate victory but renewed
instability seems the most likely
results
Emma heard Sky News Johannesburg